i saw one where they did like the tick
tockers versus uh
youtubers that's this weekend i think is
it oh cool [ __ ]
uh who the [ __ ] cares about that and
they try to sell it
on a press conference so they try to do
a fake fight and it's like
the guy tried to swing at him but he
just reached for his leg and then they
broke it up and it was like the worst
thing ever
india was like a big ass brawl yeah bro
but unfortunately because of jake paul
and because of logan you know that's how
we're going to we're all going to see
this from now on yeah but the biggest
difference is
like at least they're training with
world-class coaches these guys are
training
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain
podcast we have the og crew bag we got
[ __ ] it
alex acosta he's back baby
vacation from florida dog hey shout out
to my florida miami folks
hey what's her name um hector eduardo
mario omarion there's all one person
that's one person right there dog i
never i would go to miami though
you should like your front miami dude
low key you'd fit in bro
is it dominican out there or cuban cuban
puerto rican
puerto rican yeah you asking the wrong
people bro
we don't know [ __ ] like chinese japanese
i don't know yeah i've never been i
would love to go though have you gone
uh what miami yeah i've been to miami
florida dude let me tell you something
about miami
so there's two places i really like in
terms of water right
it's it's like uh what florida [ __ ] like
that like that coast and then hawaii
the biggest difference between florida
and uh hawaii
is that hawaii got people that look like
me little chubby you know little titties
little [ __ ] bellies
yeah i think i blend in over there bro
let me tell you something
in hawaii you were dying piece bro hey
i'm just going right you were 10 out of
10 miami
everybody's roided up yeah and i thought
that was like some [ __ ] that people just
say because me and tim we did uh
send foods out there and i was like oh
[ __ ] the beach is out here and
almost like 15 pounds lighter than i am
now i walk there everybody's ripped
girls ass is out [ __ ] fine as hell
dudes are all ripped i kept my shirt on
all day that shouldn't make you feel
insecure bro
i went into the water with my shirt on
no matter what they're like he's not
from miami bro
if you went to hawaii you go in the
water with your shirt on no no no no
no no probably not well you don't need
to man your boy a little thick right now
but
[ __ ] i don't like it when big people
take the they have their shirt on and
they go in the water
i used to do that as a kid though you
know so it kind of feels like
that's different it's like high school
because you know people are [ __ ]
clown on you and yeah i know but like
that's what i'm saying though i did it
my whole life unless i was like at home
we had a pool at my house and i would
swim
without my shirt off and your neighbor's
like
yeah i'm like wait why the [ __ ] you in
my yard
no but yeah i think i did it for so long
it kind of just felt like
safe and comfortable you know what i'm
saying why that weird moment where i i
used to wear a shirt when i used to swim
too right then one day i was like
wait they know i'm fat you know like
this
this shirt don't protect that i'm
[ __ ] fat it just looks like a wet
t-shirt contest yeah
yeah yeah and you win it bro but low-key
too like even
like anton champ he's better like even
when we went swimming i take my shirt
off but
it's true though because like when you
wear your shirt it like makes you stick
out even more it looks worse
yeah so like like if you're fat whatever
like that you can just take off your
shirt people are just
like oh okay cool but when you have that
shirt i was like hey he's wearing a
shirt because he think he fat
and then everybody's like hey look he's
wearing a shirt because he thinks he's
fat don't matter
hey but nowadays though bro it's like
you're not you're not considered
fat yeah you you kind of you just swole
bro you're kind of big you just got dead
lifting bro it's like what let's see how
much you deadlift them cuz
i so i i decided to go in and like i
lift i've been lifting in recently
i decided to go in and kind of test my
numbers i still got some strength on me
a little bit oh yeah no [ __ ] guys yeah
get the [ __ ] out
let me just give you this little
background we'll be going into the gym
and none of us have deadlifted i don't
know like let's say like three years
four years
i'm putting i don't know maybe like a 15
plate
maybe a little time maybe like one third
of the time right there real quick
i'm hitting them the bars this is still
low as [ __ ] yeah
basically the [ __ ] barbell is still
on the floor
this will put it up like [ __ ] like 2
25 he goes crack
i still got it he just drops it like
it's nothing and we were like oh yeah
no [ __ ] bro yeah squatted the biggest
one for me that shocked me was my squat
cause i still hit
uh 500 and i hadn't like squatted what
the [ __ ] how's that possible yeah 500.
the [ __ ] i don't know bro hey when i was
eating good over quarantine
i think when i weighed myself when we
weighed ourselves when we did the thing
was
254 i think it was so i mean that kind
of makes sense it's doubling my body
weight
i was a little surprised though this
[ __ ] kind of yo double my body weight
bro i can't do [ __ ]
yeah literally because we started
working out because we did that weight
loss bet that we're all losing
like yeah what's what's the status on
that right now
who do you think is gonna be in last
place gilbert i think it's gonna be gil
gilbert just got a weird shaped body so
we wouldn't even know how to judge that
i don't know
ethel's [ __ ] areola ratio is all off
he's still wearing that same hawaiian
shirt from when we [ __ ] made the
contest
low-key every time i've seen gilbert
he's wearing that same fear definitely
is shaped like a summer squash dude like
i don't know how the [ __ ]
we got to see what seasonal fruit he
looks like when he tastes like shirts so
it's funny because
for the people that don't know we
started doing a weight loss competition
but it was funny because like
me and david had the same thought
because he told me like i got home
because i have all the
pictures on my phone and i was like
looking through them
and i was like hmm i'm like damn we all
kind of ugly yeah
i know yeah i mean because like when we
shower or whatever we're just we're just
big that's who we are
and loki none of us take pictures of
ourselves like that never and you find
dude you are goal weight this will
driven i know he's
he's like he's like the he's the normal
person he's the normal person of the
group
i'm trying to get shreddy dog i've been
trying to get you to get shreddy for
[ __ ]
years now we got we have ten percent of
david's crypto
on the line so now we got something to
work i don't even know what the [ __ ]
that means but i'll take it
you're definitely losing dude so talking
about he has a diversion towards salad
and [ __ ]
i know hey i haven't eaten good though
but i've been pooping a lot
good for you i was also sick though so
like i had diarrhea and and throwing up
you have food poisoning so that probably
puts you under
but good i low-key that ain't fair hey
we gotta get on food poisoning bro
don't get me wrong i'll beat you
immediately it's game over
we'll win this challenge bro all right
but we want to talk recently
about a fight yeah that happened yo
bless up lord and savior the lord and
savior jesus christ
so logan paul versus
floyd mayweather you guys both didn't
pay for it right here
i don't know i didn't pay for it i
didn't think about paying for it i
didn't even look for a stream link
i just i did fight did not interest me
at all i was excited to watch it i saw
the highlights
because it's all over instagram so you
can't not but now i was just like
i ain't going to waste my time harry
potter is on [ __ ] age but why were
you excited for it
because i just want to see what would
happen i want to see how floyd was able
to i just wanted to see
how good logan paul was going to be you
know and he was all right
you know what's interesting about that
fight so here's the thing
i i already knew somebody was just gonna
upload it on youtube before it gets
taken down so i got to see the whole
fight
after it ended it was uploaded like a
minute after
and then it got taken down after two
three hours so i got to see it like a
couple of times
yeah and it was just it was what we
expected it was floyd
mayweather in the first round just doing
nothing and he puts the bottom in the
last few rounds
which is what he did with conor mcgregor
the difference is this one only went
eight rounds yeah the thing that shocked
me the most was how
[ __ ] out of shape logan paul was like
he was breathing so heavy
what the [ __ ] like he looks so fit why
was he so tired he looks so clean too
that muscle mass is a lot of because
they weighed in he weighed in that what
190 almost i think it was he was like
he was heavy was 40 pounds that was the
thing too we had talked about it was
like everybody was like oh he couldn't
floyd couldn't even knock out logan i'm
like yeah he's 40 pounds heavier than
him and probably on fight night he was
probably bigger
yeah before sure yeah i didn't exist i
didn't i didn't expect him to knock him
out i expected
yeah what happened to happen right it's
just like it's the same exact thing with
connor i like we
i mean i'm not gonna say everybody knew
but i had a good feeling like all right
boy's probably just gonna you know mess
around obviously probably not finishing
the first round because you know it's a
spectacle you know
do this [ __ ] but i mean it just didn't
interest me because i
like a jake paul fight is different
because even though he's beat some like
people that never box la
da da da technically he has wins right
and he's fighting against people that
you know are
way lower than his skill level but he's
not going and losing every fight and
then fighting the greatest boxer of all
time
yeah like it's just it was just so
pointless and stupid i think it's
arguable
that logan paul's resume is harder than
jake paul's
100 yeah yeah a hundred percent he went
against floyd mayweather yeah and he
fought against
ksi that was a like you know he's not a
real boxer but
hey loki because logan could have
probably won that fight too did you guys
see that one it was like a split
decision loss yeah yeah yeah yeah
honestly i thought he won he dropped him
in the fight and everything like that
but
yeah it's true because i mean i think
ksi
beats any of jake paul's opponents that
jake paul you think he beats ben asking
yeah yeah yeah he white hey
ice cream bro he disappointed me in that
fight well i mean ben asked him when you
want to talk about somebody should keep
his shirt on when they swim
i was like did you not work out at all
what'd you do
it's like he was like okay i'm going to
gain weight for this fight he hasn't
seen he has those like
thick love handles like from when the
side is love handles like this
and his arms look normal yeah like it
looks like he doesn't store body fat
anywhere else but his love handles
how weird is that because he looks he
looked terrible
and he knew he was going in to fight
somebody like jake paul he's like oh
he's not a real fighter
but that dude was like a state wrestling
guy he knows how to grind he knows how
to [ __ ] he showed up to fight
yeah and it doesn't matter if he's on a
fighter he showed up to fight no
dude ben askren has to live with the
fact that he got his ass beat by dude
that did acro yoga before a fight
but i know they were doing some weird
[ __ ] but that's so that's what's a
little cringe to me he's like it's like
bro he's trying to literally
copy connor yeah like literally to the t
and it's just like
i understand it like working though
which is great i know but it's just like
man
someone do something new bro did you
guys think that lo that
mayweather knocked out uh logan because
there's that little clip that's been
floating around oh yeah kind of
i i need to see the longer clip because
that was kind of they just got tied up
yeah in that context that looks like oh
yeah it does look like he got dropped
but
dude logan was getting cracked coming in
a lot of the times by just mayweather is
just better timing this little checkup
yeah just like straight cross right
there it's like and canelo throws it
really good like that too where they
like throw their hook like this
but you can't really tell if it's going
to the body or the head
and they're just so fast and you kept
smacking him with the hook but i did see
that right because it's like it looks
like he wobbles him and he kind of falls
into him and it's like the clinch
i don't know i to me the whole thing is
like bro it's like the weight difference
at that point you know who was really
awkward on that was brennan's shop
like when he was just walking around and
he was doing like the interviews and
stuff this was like basically sucking
logan paul's dick
he was like in the back he was like bro
that's a win it's a win it's a win
that was one of those videos where like
you know like when you're homies doing
something
embarrassing and yeah you feel
embarrassed yeah like i was like wow i
would have felt like you know how do you
know why i don't even know
keep your chill bro i don't even know
it's a win
on the commentators did you hear them
that was the best part they were so
funny dude yeah
they that they need to do more fights
boards
bro they were just clowning the whole
time but like with funny ass jokes like
they were great and with maro ronaldo
ronello
they they just had the perfect
combination like they were just vibing
off each other
that was my favorite part that's what i
really watched and you could tell they
actually like fighting
yeah yeah we still like it so it was
tight that was like the worst uh
[ __ ] show i ever seen of commentating
was that [ __ ] ben asker and jake paul
that was the war i was that was so bad i
was terrible i wanted to can't he can't
believe
it or not give me my [ __ ] money and
i'm like bro this is it was just so
bad yeah commentator betting on the
fight and [ __ ]
look what happened to triller right yeah
i don't know so triller now lost jake
paul he is now an official boxer at
show time and now they're smart by
showtime do you know what their next
fighter big
star is it's tarzan the real tarzan oh i
saw yeah he's fighting victor bell
who is victor shoes the the real tarzan
got really big because he's he's a guy
who's like i'm not a marine biologist
but he [ __ ] with animals right yeah he
actually really loves animals looking
cool too
you know what that one kid with the fake
teeth the chicklet teeth what's his name
he got his ass beat at that diner i
don't know oh i don't know he's not the
real tarzan but he's like the guy who
talks to deers
oh yeah i know that dude yeah yeah he
talks to the demons and he's like yo
this is my dear yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah i know what you're talking about
now yeah so he's a really catchy name
he's the real
version of him like he's kind of
gimmicky right he just pretends to talk
to dears he kind of pretends like he
likes
animals he doesn't really like animals
he just he just got really big off of
talking to a deer
yeah you know riley said that now i
remembered that video yeah i forgot what
this was
gonna be my homie bro yeah he has this
whole social media page he talks to
[ __ ] deer yeah
so he's this deer talker but he's the
real
it's like if he was a real man and he
evolved into his next pokemon stage
that's who the real tarzan is yeah he's
like the [ __ ]
this [ __ ] is cool bro the real tires and
some of those videos are cool he loves
that he knows facts about and i think he
was like a former like d1 football
player too
so he's yoked he's a big buff black dude
yup is it does he have a video of him
washing like animals in his
bathtub everything yeah i think i've
seen that he has like 70 pit bulls
yeah huge bunch of iguanas with a bunch
of [ __ ] yeah lizards and tigers
dude his photos are beautiful as [ __ ] i
hope he knocks out vitor bell for it
you know uh he's uh [ __ ] training
with
um tyson what's his face kickboxer
uh likes getting a black dude sponge
yeah tyrone spong yeah
so he's trading with him his old his
boxing coach
trains steffy cullen uh
paige van zandt bro and tyron woodley
that his name is pedro dude oh is that
where tyron's at oh yeah
he's nice bro like he's a legend he's a
legend of miami like he he's like that
guy
dude i don't know who that guy is but
whatever he did he's tired he made paige
vanzant's hands look
so good bro he was training he used to
train all the black aliens like he was
the blo
he was the boxing coach for all the
black zillions he's trained um tyrone
spong
he's trained vitor he's training all
those dudes so he's real legit
when i saw when i saw uh pedro vanzant
training with him i was like oh she's
about to be sick bro
is that new or was she with him with the
first bare knuckle fight i don't know
i think it's new right i think it is
yeah because i think she was a top team
yeah because now she's about to fight no
she was somewhere in like washington
but now she's about to fight rachel
ostovich again i'm like that's gonna be
about to be about
yeah oh i thought you said she's not
hawaiian i was like she's hawaiian
though
oh i don't know i don't know i just feel
like yeah that's gonna beat her
yeah i do too i do too rachel she was
one of those fighters where she wasn't
that good it was just like that she was
in the ufc i feel like because it was
like the new division on the ultimate
fighter
and [ __ ] but i mean she had a terrible
run at the uk
yeah she won a fight she probably won
one she won the
she won the fight for the ufc uh the
ultimate fighter finale
she won that fight but like rear naked
choke but then she lost every other
fight she was the one that was
domestically abused yes right bro that
was the husband
they had the audio and [ __ ] like yeah i
remember that [ __ ] yeah
that's so [ __ ] sad dude yeah it's
crazy like i can't imagine a ufc fighter
getting domestically abused either
unless he was like a he was mma fighter
too oh [ __ ] okay well there you go ebay
yeah he wasn't
but i mean remember there's that one guy
he was dating the porn star christy mack
the war machine yeah bro he's like in
prison he's in jail for
he tried to kill her bro he tried to
kill her we've never heard about that
though his name was war machine john oh
yeah i heard we we didn't know
jk news years ago yeah he was trying to
murder her you're trying to murder her
and he's in like
she got away i think she got away and
then like she ran butt naked
all the way to someone's house and then
they like they're like called the cops
and [ __ ] like that
but he it not the door he's like oh [ __ ]
i know you you're on my portal
yeah supposedly they weren't together
and then she was out of her house with
another guy
like one of her friends so he came in
and beat the [ __ ] out of the guy
and then try to kill her so that's why
he's in prison for life
he beat the crap out of her he should be
set on fire bro i remember the photo she
was she was beaten up really bad yeah i
get rid of people like that
yeah yeah she got like free nose jobs
and [ __ ] memory because it was like a
big thing
it's like people were like oh we'll give
you no shot for free and that type of
[ __ ] but yeah i mean that fool
beat the [ __ ] out of here that [ __ ] was
crazy i don't know but that dude have
you seen a sparring footage of
the real tarzan no he's any good no he's
not good at all
i'm going to fight vitoria belfort that
sucks man i saw the the promotional
video do you see that so bad dude
why are they god why of all people is he
going to fight vitor
like bro to me that's the most random
bro trying to act
he's like i know you go with
domesticated animals but
we're not trained animals over here get
out oh cool live detour
and then and then he goes and then the
guy throws water at his back and then
vitor charges him and they
happen to drop the phone yeah vitor
belford might as well have read it
office of his palm
like this i know you train animals
but to not train an animal
and even tarzan's like a lion
i saw one where they did like the tick
talkers versus uh
youtubers that's this weekend i think is
it oh cool [ __ ]
uh who the [ __ ] cares about that and
they try to sell it
on a press conference so they try to do
a fake fight and it's like
the guy tried to swing at him but he
just reached for his leg and then they
broke it up and it was like the worst
thing ever
it was like a big-ass brawl yeah bro but
unfortunately because of jake paul and
because of logan
you know that's how we're getting we're
all gonna see this from now on yeah but
the biggest difference is like at least
they're training with world-class
coaches and trainers
these guys are training at [ __ ] ten
goose with people who don't give a [ __ ]
about them bro
all of them are training yeah they're
all training at ten goose with the same
coach
so it's like how the [ __ ] is this gonna
work out man it makes no sense
i literally don't care about the the
tick tocker youtuber
for that one someone's gonna get hurt
bro yeah someone is gonna get knocked
the [ __ ] out it's gonna be like [ __ ]
that
the thing that pat did when he fought
those guys
what the [ __ ] it's gonna be exactly like
that because it's like they think this
is
and also who the [ __ ] is paying money to
watch that one i have no idea
the fact that mayweather and logan got a
million
pay-per-view buys i get it because it's
mayweather and it's uh logan but like
who the [ __ ] wants to see the guy from
the ace family fight
no bro low-key though those people by
the way that's right here
they got followings dude like those
youtubers and tick tocks they got
followings
it's not even that we're all even young
people don't give a [ __ ] that much but
it's like it's like this super super
young crowd yeah it's like
15 year olds like they don't got money
though yeah they're not gonna be paying
for no paper
that's mommy's credit card right there
bro 50 bucks to watch
the [ __ ] guys that don't know what
happened you could just wait it's going
to be uploaded on youtube a week after
you'll be fine guys yeah
just chill out and wait because it's so
dumb because you're not going to see
anything fun you're not going to see
anything crazy maybe somebody will get
knocked out but who the [ __ ] really
cares
yeah especially when they're just all
like not boxers when you see the footage
of
uh the real tarzan when he mike holsten
that's his name when he's when he's
sparring this bull is definitely a noob
because he's throwing haymakers when he
spars
all he's trying to do is knock out his
sparring partners he's pretty bad but
then you know tyler spawns just keeping
it nice and cool
yeah tapping him but he's throwing his
jab like hella hard throwing [ __ ]
overhands and [ __ ] hooks
so him and dylan would be good partners
then yes it'll be hey man
hey shout out to dylan bro i just want
to say dylan
you kind of deserved it bro
dylan's like i still need to see david
and i still need to apologize to him
ah you don't need to apologize just
don't swing if you like that
he's like yo i'm sorry it was just a
little
it was a little shocking because he hit
me in the face so hard i know this full
because pj came into the shop
and he's like telling the story cut off
pj bro yeah shout out pj
and he like comes in the shop i'm
talking to pj and then he starts telling
him he's like yeah
he's like yeah i remember i went and
trained with him he's like
man i might i just remember me and david
we're going and i go and i throw a jab
at his body
and then david just he's like he just
beat the [ __ ] out of me
i literally went hold up excuse me sir
i was like excuse me i was like handsome
i was like i was like you're forgetting
a whole entire punch
it's like what are you talking about i'm
like pj not only did he throw his nice
little jab to the body
dylan closes his eyes and just [ __ ]
throws the hardest overhand he can
and it lands on david right and then i
was like i was like i
i've known dave for like two years now
so i know when david gets mad
i was like i see david's face go
dog and then so david
you know who did his thing bro it was a
three-minute round i was like
i know the boy went red bro like yeah
none of us
those are 30 punches
but hey but but dylan he does feel sorry
about it so he's like it's all good
well i think there was just a little
misinterpretation because
you know when you're hey david just want
to beat the [ __ ] out of somebody right
and it just so happened to be done i
know
place wrong time and it happens that's
what happens in the training room
sometimes
i don't like it you just wait like i
didn't feel good after yeah you don't
feel a bit dirty
yeah yeah you should have felt dirty for
that one bro like he was he had murder
in his heart
you saw it bro this dude had murdered
his eyes nobody else will corroborate
hey nick
nick was like nick walked away pat
walked away i sat there like
i was like hey just kind of fun bro i
was like hey david chill out bro like
the lighter guys
he felt bad too because like i set that
up because like i did the first round
with dylan
and right after you remember i was like
all right david go with go at dylan
i was [ __ ] chopping a instigator
right here bro i didn't know i didn't
know it was gonna go like that
you know what it is has something i
should have watched you and him spar
because i wasn't paying attention so i
didn't have any expectations
it wouldn't have helped you bro yes it
would have i would have been like oh oh
he's
he's he's not his trait i know you
wouldn't
bruh tell me this fool doesn't gass
himself up look hey hey listen listen
listen listen if somebody quacks you
hard enough and you're like
all right that's just how it goes that's
how it goes baby
and it's no fault on you kinda it's no
fun
kinda it's it's you know it's a little
less fall on dylan because you don't
know what the [ __ ] you're doing but also
you know that was david just beat the
[ __ ] out dude that was probably the
hardest somebody has
hit me with a glove because you know we
always lights bar
yeah and then when you feel your i think
the thing that made me go red like my
jaw was hurting i was like
he hurt me and then we're all calling
you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah and then nick was
in the bag's like oh you left look at
it hit you when dylan landed all of us
went
oh and then david just felt like [ __ ]
bro
hey david's hands went from this to this
he's like [ __ ] bro his hands were ready
it wasn't fighting no more it was being
big right there
are you trying to get that blit
that [ __ ] was weird though i don't
remember too much of it i just remember
i was like
i remember hey you remember what sucks
do is i wasn't recording too because
like it was just like the first round i
would have died inside yeah it was just
the first round
so like i didn't record anything because
i was like oh let's warm up a bit and
then
now you can feel the vibe though bro
like sometimes when you watch the
recording it doesn't do it justice
yeah but you felt the [ __ ] you got to be
there bro it was palpable and we got
lucky we was there bro
that was the fact we saw
you don't know no better bro you know
he's still learning his body
i do you know what actually happened
it was what uh when i first met gianni
and this was throwing hammers at me
gianni bro okay i'll say this
the white boys they throw hammers
they're spazzy bro
some white dudes are just spazzy as [ __ ]
like they're just not smooth with it
but the difference between him was that
we were going body anyways the body i
don't feel so bad yeah
okay i was trying to knock his block off
though but he do because
his yachty is a little like when he
turns it up i'm like oh [ __ ] this dude
really trying to
like
quarantine we were holding mitchell for
everybody i also only missed for his
little brother and he's a southpaw too
that pool actually has some power on him
i was like hey low-key okay
i don't want to start no [ __ ] but
christian hits harder than gianni
hey i held mitts for both of them yeah
100 you know we're talking about
yeah gianni from power your younger
brother d and him and tell him that his
younger brother
who works for fighting the kid got
better hands than you hey bro
bro start from power gianni brother
impress his brother
yeah hey gianni dude [ __ ] nick said
you're a little [ __ ] yeah i said you're
loyal and you're when i
said you're not a [ __ ] man you my
friend dude hey he trains with kevin
hall and [ __ ]
yeah dude the [ __ ] he didn't invite us
but i couldn't make it but they should
have went bro
this is the context i got especially
because it's gilbert so
you can take anything that he says with
a grain of salt shots fired
all of a sudden we could have trained
with kevin holland today but nick said
no my wife
i was like bro i was at jk news i
couldn't go i was like wait
i was like wait what and then nick's
like you guys just go
and i'm like are you serious and then i
might kept asking are you serious and
they just kept having their conversation
i was like i'm so confused i don't know
what's going on right now for serious
man i'll double a kevin hallen right now
hey let me teach you how to wrestle bro
hey kevin if you listen to this before i
even go for a leg he would knock my
teeth out dude
his hands are so fast so the homie
elliot he uh
he's he trains with those guys he trains
out in like i think dallas or whatever
the [ __ ]
and he was saying like yo he's seen you
know
uh kevin hall and spar with some guys in
the welterweight division that you know
that are like up there and he's like bro
kevin holland is really like that like
he's in the gym just talking [ __ ] and
he's just like that
he's just that guy and he's he's just be
beating the brakes off some of these
dudes bro
i wonder why they won't let him go to
170. they won't let him
well i just well like he actually
get to 170. he's [ __ ] huge no but he
weighs in like at 183
every time oh yeah he never he says he
never really cuts weight he's like izzy
then
yeah very light i think for for kevin
holland it's like he's had so much
success at 185
yeah with that weight and stuff so but
imagine though like just
like test the waters go down to 170. you
don't want [ __ ] camaro loseman dude
yeah he'll take those long limbs and
[ __ ] break them off yeah
like i listen i love kevin holland dude
but nobody's [ __ ] like
marcus i was like
kevin all right not kevin newsman camaro
it's starting to get up there i got to
for me for like one of the
one of the tomorrows yeah bro he's
goated right now yeah he's goat right
now
like no who's who's better than him i
don't know with that mentality
i kind of wish izzy wasn't at 185
because i would like to see him go up 25
but he said he'd never fight
and the only reason why i'm saying that
is because we saw you know the problem
in kevin holland's game when it came
to the ground game specifically him
against the cage whether it's on his
back or whatever
yeah kamara oozman that's his specialty
when you talk about the worst thing that
could ever happen to kevin holland would
become our husband and that's why kamar
is such a style matchup nightmare for
everybody in the division
now he has a jab too what the [ __ ] are
you gonna do now he's working with
trevor whitman
knocking out jorge mosfet all games like
over pretty easily
you know like the worst he barely broke
a sweat in that fight yeah
and and jorge monsignol was really
[ __ ] good like he made him look
average
yeah you know so that [ __ ] was crazy if
he fights a guy
if he fights steven wonder boy thompson
as as much of a fan i am of him
and of his style i just don't think his
style is going to match up very well
with uh
with kamaru dude that's the one fight
for me for some reason i'm like i feel
like stephen can win though
i really do i just feel like his long
stance
his takedown defense is good but he's
going to be longer than kamaru and he's
such a good karate like point fire
that he might be able to stay away from
those takedowns and he might be able to
keep his distance
i've been watching a lot of steven
wonderboy thompson sparring [ __ ]
he's just a really awkward guy yeah yeah
awkward he just
he gets people's timing really fast his
in and out in and out [ __ ] and you'd
never know when his league
lead leg is going to hit you in the head
yeah that's the weird part even when i'm
watching the video i can't catch it i'm
like
i didn't expect him to throw his lead
leg to the head like that and it's so
quick yeah his setups are so good and
he's literally standing sideways so it's
like what the [ __ ] is this phil doing
how are you supposed to defend against
something like that i don't know bro
yeah like
i i don't i don't i don't understand
what the because i gotta eat a couple i
guess
yeah and then you just have to deal with
it yeah because i was watching a bunch
of
these karate guys that are adjusting
into mma
and you know they have this long stance
which you know it tends to get low
kicked a lot
but they're so quick and then before you
even low kick them they're sidekicking
you in the gut or they're hitting you in
the head
yeah how hard is that well any time
wonder boy fights anybody
even when he loses it's always a really
tough fight yeah person
yeah it's always uh the tyrant said the
hardest fights of his whole entire
career
yeah because it's so awkward you don't
know like he has knockout power
he's so tricky and it's like though it's
the worst when you're sparring against a
guy that you don't know what the [ __ ] is
gonna happen
and like to take that and then you take
it against floyd
and logan right logan is obviously not a
traditional boxer he's not a high level
boxer
so like when you see a guy like floyd
spar a guy like him or fight a guy like
him
this podcast is brought to you by
bluetooth fellas i know there are some
of you out there that don't feel like a
stallion in the bedroom well guess what
you limp dick leonard
you don't have to be ashamed because i
got the solution for you and that
solution
is blue chew even my young friend kermit
approves miss piggy and i have been
together for many years
and uh let's just say the little froggy
wouldn't leap anymore so your boy had to
get some blue chew and i gotta tell you
it was riveting that's my word kermit
thank you for
coming in and saying such great things
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost blue chews tablets help men
achieve harder
stronger erections to combat all forms
of e
d that's right men yeah you get the help
you need and ladies if your mans need
some help
get them some blue chew it's an online
prescription service so no awkward
visits or conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet
package listen we got a special deal for
our listeners try out bluetooth for free
when you use our promo code brain at
checkout just pay five dollars for
shipping
that's bluechew.com promo codebrain to
receive your first month free
and we thank bluechu for sponsoring our
yeah podcast much actually right
basically and it's like
he's trying to figure out what the [ __ ]
he's gonna do because he's so out of
left field
you know like his style his setups
everything he does it's probably so
awkward and herky-jerky that he's
probably never seen before he's used to
seeing like smooth
boxers yeah like real legit boxers who
who he could read like a book
but you get a guy like logan who's kind
of spazzy you know and you don't know
what the [ __ ] gonna happen
that's why the whole first two rounds
he's like okay he's trying to pick up on
his tendencies a little bit
and he's so awkward so it's like and
it's you could see too
the the experience in what like a
seasoned boxer has versus somebody who's
not
because you could see how much energy
logan is expending yeah the moment that
he had
mayweather cornered yeah he started
throwing hay makers
yeah and he wanted that look yeah floyd
was like let's go and then after that
gassed out he had nothing left in his
tank and all floyd had
none of it was landing
he actually did connect to floyd's
temple yeah with like a cross
it was like a jab and then it crossed
over yeah yeah he just kind of grazed
him and that's the thing about like
everyone's like oh how come he didn't
knock him out it's
like i don't think floyd thought about
it like
he he was assessing the possibility of
him getting hit and he was like nah it's
okay
not worth i'm not going to risk it i'm
not going to risk getting hit by this
[ __ ] kid
yeah he he cracked him hard a couple
times with that hook hit him with the
[ __ ] little a step back little cross
yep and you have to realize too it was
only eight rounds if that [ __ ] went to
12 rounds oh yeah yeah
he probably would have cooked he would
have got knocked out yeah
and that's like floyd mayweather's style
he just wears you out
and when you have nothing left in your
tank he's going to crack you and he
needs a connor
yeah even when he fights up like regular
pro boxers
he he kind of just does enough to win
and he's like got my w
yeah i didn't get hit i got my w he
literally called it up
he goes why wouldn't i this was a heist
it's amazing i love that about him bro
yeah
and and it's true because he saw
something in logan he goes
most people most boxers at that level
would be like kind of uh they'd be ego
tripping a little bit like i ain't gonna
fight this dude
like for what like he's never done
anything but mayweather is the only guy
who actually kind of created this genre
anyway
of fights of freak show fights and he
goes oh i can make a lot of money off
this [ __ ] kid well the cool thing
about him is too is that he's already
proved his legacy yeah so he has nothing
to lose he's like i'm going to the hall
of fame
i wonder how much he actually trained
for this fight he said i cut like every
other day
a couple times a week he's always
training like that i don't think yeah
exactly
i don't think he trained i think he just
lived his normal life because he just
goes
you know he doesn't go he does go to the
gym and [ __ ]
and probably just like [ __ ] i'm about
but that's that's what's so crazy right
he's like all right just give me the
first two rounds i'll see what this
michael bisping was like
super irritated um because
i listened to his podcast and he was
like
disappointed in logan and he was also
kind of disappointed that mayweather
didn't knock out logan paul
which you know i mean i understand he's
a fighter and stuff but at the same time
like
why would he need to yeah and also too
like logan you saw what happened he
gassed out because he threw
everything he threw i think in those
first two rounds my thing is
bro it's like bro i mean it's not like
logan's like some old ass dude right
yeah he's like no he's like 45
24 yeah that's crazy so like he's 24
he's young
he probably hasn't been in that many
fights if anything
probably now that he's sparring and [ __ ]
like that i mean and he's also 40 pounds
heavier than him like he really i didn't
i didn't expect him to knock him out
yeah
bro it was funny too because in the
first like few rounds you just see
mayweather smiling at him
i was like dad he's literally like
mocking this dude i think if there was
ever going to be a finish
everybody kind of expected like oh body
shots get him tired yeah
wear him out standing tko something like
that overwhelm him
but even then he didn't have to do that
yeah he just had to let him throw yeah
he just kept his guard high but
yeah i don't think anyone thought he was
gonna like kale and like head shot just
bang hit him right in the chain and put
him to sleep you know what was kind of
nutty
[ __ ] uh logan paul's reach was only
an inch longer than mayweather's
damn really i had no idea how long he's
a lot taller than him too huh yes
he seems like he got some long-ass arms
doesn't he mayweather's five
eight yeah yeah and then logan's like
six two
yeah that's a weird statistic yeah
so [ __ ] got some really which
kind of makes sense because like i know
mayweather he
he blocks to his body really well so he
has those longer arms yeah
covers up his body he's just a shield
yeah
built for boxing like it's like perfect
you said he can just go like this and
he's like already blocking his body and
[ __ ] like that but who you got for tyron
and jake i think tyrant about to put it
on him
do you think jake is better than uh
logan uh yeah i re i do
i do after this fight i don't know i i
won't see those two brothers fight
logan you know what he's not that bad
he he got better he definitely got
better but i don't know if he's better
than jake
i mean logan problematically he's going
to have trouble when he fights somebody
his size because he can't keep his hands
down like that
the only reason why he got away with
that is because [ __ ] mayweather is
five foot eight
yeah that's the only reason why you keep
it low and flip you know flicker that
jab out he's doing that with somebody at
his height and like
with the longer reach he's [ __ ] yeah
what's he gonna do yeah and mayweather
was walking his ass
down which was so weird crazy to see
this little [ __ ]
little man walk down this giant
throughout the whole ring i'm like yo
what the [ __ ] is happening yeah i don't
know i just i just think
i think tyron's a different level yeah
like he's still not
that professional boxer that everybody
wants to see jake paul fight
but i mean i mean it's different like
he's a striker he knocks
he has knockouts from punches right like
he's
one punch knockout power and then even
just watching him hit
mitts and do these drills that they're
just releasing you're like
okay fire bro okay so this this is like
this for real if if jake can beat tyron
um
i'll give him a little bit of credit
yeah i want that's gonna happen too just
because you know mma striking especially
with hands is so different from boxing
now that we've seen it so much right
because tyron likes to throw
specifically a lot of looping shots yeah
and jake paul is always straight down
yeah
that's his kryptonite it's been like
that in the mma fights so unless timer
starts learning to throw a [ __ ] jab
yeah i think it's going to change
because of the mma
like not worrying about take because
he's not worried about takedowns he's
not worrying about getting takedowns
either so
we'll see what happens but you guys know
my boy haas bula
oh my god boy you know right i do
the little kid that's been going around
all over sounds like a little chat
yeah bro he's fighting nate robinson
what's happening bro
okay so you know the guy he's always
with right yeah the russian cat oh yeah
the guy the big neck
apparently he's going to box jake paul
before tyron woodley
what yeah and he has mma fight but he's
like when you see him fight you're like
oh this [ __ ] just a big
yeah he's just a big it's like he's a
big strong guy like he he don't really
have any boxing experience it seems like
he just throws haymakers
okay but like he knows how to [ __ ]
people up you know but
we'll see what happens but he's supposed
to he's supposedly gonna fight a box
in a couple of weeks or some [ __ ] really
like a little tune-up yeah but the whole
thing with that
is like um that's the point of that that
guy's famous as [ __ ] out in russia too
yeah i watched i watched the like on
youtube they have like before they were
famous things
i'm fascinated by that but that that guy
used to be like because his neck
is like the biggest neck in the world he
was just roided out
just [ __ ] massive ass guy so he was
like a superstar out there
so that's he's famous he's hospital's
manager bro but i remember seeing house
boula and the other guy
and i remember i remember saying i was
like is are these little kids though
because for some reason they look like
older they are little kids bro
but yeah they're 18 right 18 and 19 but
they
the other guy's like a famous musician
yeah yeah i know his music comes in
bags bro and he's sitting that little
[ __ ]
he's taking his heart out bro
all i know is that the reason why it was
so hard to figure out they were kids or
an adult is because the proportions are
right
yeah all the proportions are just
they're five-year-olds yeah
they're they're like just regular
fighters for me like when i saw like a
close-up of his face his skin looked
older yeah so i was like i think they
might be old i don't know if they're
like kids or not i just want to know
what they're saying bro i know huh
because you know they're not they're not
both dagestani ones from a whole
different country
so when they had that little thing where
they were sitting in the chairs and like
the hospital kicks them
yeah that's why they all had like
earpieces and
a phone because they were doing
translations dude they're the best
they're so funny my explore page was all
husbands i was telling him i
i've never made my life i never made
myself laugh so hard
when he sent us the picture with him in
the strawberries
that strawberry straight up look like a
[ __ ]
apple and i was like imagine eating two
strawberries and being full of
dinner i have to laugh so hard for that
[ __ ] i don't know why
dog he held those [ __ ] strawberries
like
this like straight up like this i was
like how small is this kid
bro this dude with the other kid what's
the other kid's name i don't know
yeah but there was there's a video going
out where he picks up a hamburger
and he's like dancing he goes burger
bro and he goes and he goes and takes a
bite and it's literally like
this big of a bite he's like only bit
the meat because you know the meat comes
out of the bun a little bit
he only bit the meat they give this
yeah it's weird because you don't get to
see perspectively how big how small
they're until that strawberry yeah i
know really like
if you guys get some strawberries like
that out here bruh bro if you're
watching this
on video on the podcast i'm look at my
hand he was holding it like
like it was a softball yeah i was like
bro he probably full as [ __ ] off
one bro it reminded me of honey i shrunk
the kids when they saw all those big ass
foods
like yo it was crazy i like them though
it's entertaining
i would pay to watch that fight just
because it's funny and i would too
they're doing i feel like they're doing
so good like building them up like
people
love these kids they did a little hype
up video of them training on flipping
tires yeah and then hospital is flipping
the small ass little bike tire
get the [ __ ] out of here dude bro i went
in a deep dive dog
yeah like i'm obsessed with these little
kids i don't think he would start
posting him when he gets a haircut and
[ __ ]
anytime i could get an opportunity to
post them but i will
what do you know what the condition is
that he that they have no
so you don't care about them on a human
level i forgot the name of
the [ __ ] i forgot the name of it but
it's like apparently he doesn't have
puberty
they don't go through puberty and they
just have the [ __ ] the body of a
five-year-old
so they don't it's like webster bro that
we could see with our eyes
yeah [ __ ] this guy basically they use a
little baby
they don't grow up they don't they don't
they don't go bigger in sizes
yeah that's it we see that with our eyes
you piece of [ __ ]
tell us something about the doctor bro
trust me uh nah
yeah he got webster disease remember
webster oh it's a disease now that's the
[ __ ] that's what it's called
it's a disease now man you got the gary
coleman the is that gary coleman
hey i don't know man but you know oh i
know yeah
he was always but he's not a famous tv
show right yeah but i don't think he was
he was proportionate too right there's
not as much though
yeah not as much they're even smaller
than gary coleman though yeah yeah
they're like
little kids like they're even smaller
than a normal five-year-old i feel like
i think
i think it's like webster do you
remember webster yes
he didn't get as big as gary coleman it
seemed like
i remember like like what was the name
vernon the guy who played mini me
oh yeah yeah yeah that's that's
something else he yeah
because they weren't proportioned he
wasn't proportioned he's like a dwarf
not like a little person
a little person he has like the little
person syndrome yeah not the m word
don't even think about it
what master what is that yeah what is it
yeah yeah
no because like at least vern or it was
just
a word don't say it bro don't say vernon
is that his name yeah vernon troyer yeah
see because his voice got deeper still a
little adult
yeah yeah but their their voices are
literally literally like
higher pitched than like a little kid
like a little kid yeah plays with
monkeys bro that's my favorite bro
though there's a video where he starts
chasing a chicken
bro there's a video where he's petting a
cat and the shit's almost as big as him
bro it's like a lion huh he's like down
like this and he's like rubbing his
whole body i'm like [ __ ]
he's like jaguar oh my god objective
from 70's videos i haven't seen this one
right every time tiff
looks on my phone i'm always watching
i'm just scrolling okay
i just want to meet him and hug him bro
yeah like i just think he's so cute
what what is your obsession with this
man i'm obsessed with
dagestani's in general i'm obsessed with
habib i'm obsessed with their whole
culture bro
i'm fascinated by it and then there's a
little guy who talks like habib but
it's like a small child fascinated he's
gonna start doing ramadan and [ __ ] yeah
i'm about to bro i'm gonna try it out i
just wanna see what's up
i'll smell we should we should put it
out right now we going to put money on
this
gonna win tyron woodley or jake paul t
wood
i got t wood what do you got i'm just
gonna go against the grain i'm gonna say
jake paul you know why because
everything i guess goes the opposite
boom oh let's hope so i just i just
listen if tyron woodley [ __ ]
loses literally la he already [ __ ] up
when he fought uh [ __ ] colby
covington and he had blm on his head
and that [ __ ] yeah the whole black
culture just was like you know
especially against colby bro hey who's
more hated
colby covington or jake paul jake paul
jake paul because nobody no i guess
loki colby he's he's really funny
like because you know what he's doing is
a total shtick
yeah his his his nicknames for everybody
marty fake newsman for kamara oozman
that makes me [ __ ] giggle dude hey
look at my face nobody else huh yeah
that's how unfunny it is
oh man you know what the thing about
kobe covington is is like
he's just an amazing fighter yeah so
it's like i i i want to see him in the
cage again i
really want to see him fight again
because he's dope as [ __ ] all i know is
that kamar oozeman with trevor whitman
colby's about to get knocked out even
faster than he did in the first fight
yeah i don't know man i think they
should have just had him fight leon bro
i think leon is a problem for anybody
leon bro
i think he has the best shot at
dethroning you want to talk about some
[ __ ]
mismatches dude you [ __ ] why is he
fighting nate nate diaz
yo shout out to nate diaz man you yo i
love you bro but if he wins though
hey dude the fight is tomorrow yes and
this episode is actually going to go up
this sunday
just to let you know he's going to lose
like
probably no there's no there is no
probably nate diaz is going to he's
going to leon edwards
yeah and then you have [ __ ] max
holloway against rodriguez
that fight makes me out that makes me
more nervous we had talked about it but
i just
like i'm excited for the fight because
i'm always excited to watch max fight
like he's my favorite one of my favorite
fighters but it just makes no sense
it makes no sense why doesn't right here
get to fight [ __ ] max hollow yeah bro
max should just wait for that title he
just beat the
the i personally think one of the best
barks boxers
in ufc he just beat the [ __ ] out of him
in boxing yeah like he shouldn't have to
do anything else to earn himself that
title shot again
especially how close the second fight
was but i mean
for me personally i feel comfortable
with that fight like i think max is
gonna
yeah max is gonna handle his [ __ ] on
that i [ __ ] hope so i think nair's
gonna get this [ __ ]
yeah dude i mean even look at this right
with him against korean zombie he won by
a fluke
yeah but korean zombie was piecing his
ass up that was the most upsetting fight
i've ever seen
he shouldn't have lost like just the way
it all ended
i literally sat on my tv and i just sat
there for like 10 minutes just staring
at it yeah that was one of those fights
i was just like
oh my god like i can't believe like
that's just something where you're just
like this really actually just happened
this is insane
he decides to throw some weird ass
[ __ ] bent over
elbow like as he was picking something
off the floor that's what knocked him
out yeah like that's what knocked him
out
cold like he just dead yeah dead yeah it
looked like he got shot
yeah and just [ __ ] he fell on top of
his back yeah well that's the thing too
is like
with him specifically he always gets
overexcited and he overreaches
and he gets this is what always happens
and every time i think that he's getting
better and better
he likes he likes to brawl korean rage
bro he just likes fighting dude
all he did was see dylan in his eyes i
was like yo come on
it was like the last five it was like a
buzzer beater wasn't it yeah it was
literally
literally four minutes 59 seconds into
the fifth round and then yair landed
that out
all he had to do was just disengage and
he would have won but he was like nah
let's go let's go let's [ __ ] throw
he's like hug me real quick again hug me
yeah you're hugged him 30 times in that
fight for some reason nope
and but yeah i'm comfortable with max i
think he's going to win that fight i
don't think he shouldn't have i should
have taken it
i just don't know why yeah even gets the
shot to fight the number one contender
especially because his last one is
jeremy stevens who
jeremy steven's cool but he was also
ranked like number eight was it didn't
he get pop for
something oh jeremy no [ __ ] yeah he
got
popped he got suspended for six months
yeah because he
was missing to his drug test yeah
yeah but then the thing with that fight
too is that he
he won the first round yeah year second
round really close
third round lost to jeremy stevens yeah
and remember that fight was supposed to
be five rounds but yahya poked him in
the eye in the first five that's right
then they rematch and instead of it
being five rounds it was only three
and then jeremy stephens started beating
the [ __ ] out of him was that a main
event third round
it was a main event but when they
rescheduled it wasn't it was just on the
card
so like imagine if he was still five
rounds jeremy stevens probably be
fighting max hawley right now nobody
wants to fight jeremy stevens five
rounds though
i don't know they they want to [ __ ]
get him out in the first three scary as
[ __ ]
well he just pushed he pushed that one
phone broke oh your car
closed yeah yeah lightweight right bro
yeah you want to talk about a short
[ __ ] temper dude
that guy he did nothing he just he was
like he was in my face okay
it's a face off it's called the face off
so
look at this clip of this dude named
jeremy stevens and jakar close
right spell that good luck yeah
draw d-r-a-k-k-a-r-k-l-o-s-e close thank
you he's an arizona fighter
we uh one time we were in the corner
with jeremy stevens and he is one of the
most intense [ __ ] of all time
like he's in the back screaming loud as
[ __ ] and we're just like he also has one
of the most intense cowlicks of all time
too that's probably why he's so intense
he's an intense dude if you watch this
face off literally jacquard close
gets in his face like a normal face-off
like a foot away two three feet away and
he goes you're too close man
probably pushing him hard he shoved him
into another universe he got a car
his forehead almost touched his own
chest yep like
i was like god he got him bro he got
concussed he had like a misplaced
vertebrae yeah from how hard he put is
your car closes like what the [ __ ]
like why'd you do that you got too close
to me and everybody's
he was actually a normal distance from
you man yeah any kind of reason he
wanted to push him he shoved them super
hard i could just picture dana white
going what the [ __ ]
yeah bro he was mad yeah he was mad at
the i think sean shelby right here is
the guy that was uh
he goes dude you should have [ __ ]
held on to them but they did pay dracar
close which is cool they paid him his
money
yeah and diego sanchez san diego uh and
diego sanchez oh
shout out to diego sanchez gaining some
of his sanity back right
yeah what do you think is gonna happen
to joshua fabia i know but remember i
had i have this theory that this might
all be a conspiracy theory what if
they're trying to get even more clout so
they're like
let's play off this breakup because
diego sanchez was supposed to come out
the week after and have this whole press
conference talk about it he never did
well i'll say this that if he's doing it
for clout right so let's say he gets
resigned to the ufc for that one last
fight again
they're definitely going to put in the
stipulation that joshua phoebe can't be
there yeah
so either way ceasing to sit on the
[ __ ] yeah he's not he's not
going to be anywhere
near allowed near any ufc [ __ ] at all
he brought a knife and he tried to try
to stab people
yo what the [ __ ] he's like listen look
if i have a knife what are you gonna do
bro you're not teaching us anything new
he's like see you're moving faster
though aren't you yes
yeah that was a rationale because you
pulled out a knife out of [ __ ]
nowhere bro
dude the the upside down video i didn't
know there was more
yeah there's a whole thing he's not just
one time he had a photo shoot bro like
he had a video shoot for that
he's like throwing [ __ ] like
roundhouse kicks to his head it's all
professional too he probably
and it has that stupid little like music
that's that massage parlors going on in
the background where it's like a
waterfall sound too you're just like
what the [ __ ] is going on these
relaxation
noise machine you want to noises about
[ __ ] gaslighting he's he's trying to
spin the narrative that is like diego
sanchez is the mastermind
yeah nobody has ever looked at diego's
hand just said this guy's a smart guy
yeah like nobody has ever looked at him
as a mastermind of anything
if any it's only making himself look
worse yeah everybody already hates you
and then you're gonna flip the narrative
and try to throw everything on diego
like that's not gonna make people be
like you know what joshua fabia
you you know what i feel aware the
things he says dude
like we talked about last time was it
here where we talked about yeah
where he said like oh i've been five two
my whole life so like i know my baby
yeah
we're talking about the [ __ ] yeah yeah
dog like that is crazy what is he
talking about you are excited
in my body longer than everybody else of
course it's you
yeah yeah what is he saying and you're
five
two he goes there is no other person on
earth
that knows what's inside my body i was
like of course because
it's you jackass like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
i know what it's like to be born in this
body oh [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you talking i can't believe
he comes up with this stuff and he
he thinks it's all good like he's really
comfortable it's crazy
but it's not but it is crazy that
there's like
people that just buy into it shout out
to his [ __ ] jiu jitsu move that he
was trying to teach everybody
where you sit down and you push your ass
out did you see this
no it is the worst video ever so he's
basically teaching you how to
like it's the opposite of doing a double
leg right he's like well why would you
reach for the leg when you could
literally
force the energy backwards and scoot
your butt back and push
if i do that i break your legs
wait hold on i don't understand it but
so like let me
demonstrate it real quick yeah yeah let
me just show you what it is
oh so you can't get taken down so it's
basically what you're doing
so that's what i mean so he basically
wants to throw you he wants you to throw
your ass into their like
private parts you're throwing your back
to them so you could break their knees
and now can i say something though
i ko'd [ __ ] this dude okay this is
this is different
this dude threw a cross at me i spun
around my ass at him dropped him bro
different brother brother brother we
were boxing brother
no wrestler i didn't i didn't expect a
comic book bomb to the butt
to the front butt he fell from
there was one where he taught an arm
drag and arm drag is when you kind of
pretty much pull someone's arm across
your body so they
they you can get their back and he would
throw he would
pull an arm drag and then slap him in
the face and he'd do this like
yeah am i right bro
when he does that he makes like the
little face like as if like you're
[ __ ] dumb for not
dude you didn't think of this yeah you
didn't think about doing this
okay it's like i mean there's a lot of
interesting people right because i i was
online and i'm watching this guy
and there's no disrespect to this dude
right i think that
i mean he teaches uh i think like
self-defense and like kickboxing and
stuff
uh i forgot what his youtube channel is
but he's like this bald dude he's like a
redhead
and he's teaching kickboxing tutorials
i'm like okay he sounds like he knows
what he's talking about
and then he goes my first pkb i was like
hold on a second
oh yeah your first pkb match this is
your first kickboxing match and it's
point sparring
and then you have a whole [ __ ] studio
where you're teaching people how to
kickbox
how [ __ ] dare you i saw his pkb match
the worst thing i've ever seen in my
life
he wasn't very good he's trying to throw
jumping backs straight kicks
he's doing like this leaping [ __ ]
low-key well they worked though so no he
was getting his ass beat by guy that was
terrible
right that's not good and then there's
this other guy who's like an mma fighter
too he's like this big black dude he's
actually really dope he kind of he kind
of fights like one boy thompson a little
bit
so he does the the very dangerous lead
uh leg kick to the head and stuff that
you don't see
but that younger guy is like his teacher
and i don't even think he owns the
studio that he owns
i'm like what the [ __ ] bro it's like bro
you've never fought before and then when
i look at his stuff and he's you know he
talks about stuff very confidently so it
sounds like you know what he's talking
about yeah
and i see him fight i'm like you have no
right to teach anybody anything
like you are not a fighter but he has
like millions of subscribers
and people just sucking his dick off in
the comments there's
i don't know what it is but i've been
going down a rabbit hole of like people
that are just
they give fitness advice on youtube or
they do fighting advice on whatever
and it's just crazy to see how many
people
that these coaches are giving
information to and how many viewers
and what a platform they have and people
are buying into it
there's this whole like there's this
whole like toxic [ __ ] alpha male
fitness uh on youtube and these guys are
like
you know if you want a lady you you
always have to treat her like [ __ ] kinda
they relay this into like fitness and
they're like yeah like you know real
alpha male is this
and it's just dude it's so bad and it's
everywhere
it's [ __ ] everywhere and some of
these poor people they have [ __ ] no
idea
they're not supposed to know hey let me
just tell you this online dating
is full of those type of dudes yeah so
uh i don't obviously online date men
anymore
so one of one of my friends she's on
she's online dating all the time right
and i wanted to see the type of men that
are on
whatever what do you call this your
bumble yeah yeah you know
yeah coffee and donuts or whatever that
[ __ ] grinder yeah grinder my favorite
though
i know hey what kind of coffee and donut
[ __ ] never gonna get a date on
that [ __ ] though
yeah let's go bro yeah alex alex got a
girl he booed up so they're
on this like online dating [ __ ] right
they're doing this thing and i'm reading
everybody's profile all these dudes
profiles right
it's it's it's the funniest [ __ ]
thing you could tell these guys that
number one
they read a self-help book on how to hit
on women
yeah it's all the same tactics and they
address women as
if they're doing a a job interview so
it'll be some [ __ ] like this so she told
me
off the jump huh so she's doing this she
went on this date right and i asked her
how it went and she goes it was the
worst i was like well what did this guy
say she goes same [ __ ] that every guy
says she goes this guy comes up
they have a conversation he goes oh hi
this is my name whatever what now
they're having coffee he goes
so what is your 10-year plan whoa on a
[ __ ] date what is what is your
10-year plan
where did you see yourself in five years
it was your day your plan
tell me an experience where you had a a
horrible customer and you had to
imagine what are some of your weaknesses
as she's telling me this i'm like no
[ __ ] way
this guy said that because there's no
[ __ ] way he asked for your 10-year
plan and where do you see yourself
[ __ ] cook he's asking her as if he's
the boss
yeah and she's on a job interview this
is like that
fake male machismo type of like alpha
male [ __ ] when you're a little bitch-ass
[ __ ]
you don't [ __ ] talk to people like
that what the [ __ ] are you talking about
guess how long that date lasted 10
minutes and she was like this isn't
working out she gets up and leaves
yeah and i'm bet you this guy's like
well i read this book
it doesn't work that [ __ ] don't work on
everybody though i asked her like what's
your best and worst quality
like get the [ __ ] how do you how do you
supposed to respond to that
who how on a first date who the [ __ ] how
how what was she supposed to say
i think i could muster myself up to ask
that on the first day
yeah like i'll be like so um uh 10
10 years why what
watch something like what's the number
10. so confidently
in the 10th year of from tomorrow what
are you going to do
if you read their profiles it's
something that everybody always does
50 of the dudes online they always use
office jokes from the office
a michael scott joke stop doing that
[ __ ] yeah
i hate that [ __ ] bro because it's like
it's a really good show
you don't need to use this as a tactic
to get girls
and she's like i'm looking at corny as
[ __ ] when she said this i thought she
was exaggerating
every guy uses a michael scott quote and
then i'm like bro what the [ __ ]
is prison mike though they use prison
the defense is the we gruel every day
the other thing that they do i probably
do this which is [ __ ] dumb listen if
you're an ugly [ __ ] guy
they're gonna see you in person the
other ways first profile pic on the
dating [ __ ]
it's always a picture that's in a
distance
and they got a mask on and a sunset and
they don't know what their face looks
like
second photo is a picture of eight guys
how the [ __ ]
are you supposed to know who the [ __ ]
you are
it's so stupid but when you read their
profile clearly just by your photos it
shows
that you are not a confident person and
the first thing you say on your
descriptor
i'm a confident man i'm a bonfire man
a man ball for that bro bro you can't
you can't say you're confident
yeah you can't do that that's not okay
it's just so [ __ ] terrible but this
is these guys
read these like hey this is how to date
books and these guys get [ __ ] up
they don't know how to act like a
[ __ ] human being well they don't have
their own personality
yeah they don't know what it is like
you're using some other guy
that's why i feel like doing [ __ ] like
that would be like it would be
someone like me right like before like
if
everybody knows i feel like trying to
follow something like that would be just
a disaster for me
because like i'm trying to like i'm
basically like faking all this [ __ ]
right and then when it comes i'm like
i'm not even bro i always wanted to just
do this thing
where you have an earpiece in yeah and
[ __ ] i just talked to you
throughout the whole thing
i just got to say exactly what i tell
you to do i'm like you want to go get
some my mice what are they going to do
[Laughter]
i was like alex ask her what she smells
like
say it right now i'm like what so if can
i smell you
and i just go perfect she's scared this
is where you want her
now she's [ __ ] scared like they're on
headlines right now
ask her what the color of her area was
her now
so um you what color oreos do you eat
what is her reaction alex oh she doesn't
like oreos
she leaves right now as she's leaving
whistle at her really hard and say my
dick
is going in that butt
uh
she just hella walks away hear that [ __ ]
show her you're the alpha male
by breaking a glass bottle over her head
actually oh i would say over my head
that's ain't no problem
oh my [ __ ] that's locked in right there
if it's like that
yo that's what i want you to do you
should have started with abraham those
[ __ ] bran
those first dates just walk up with the
[ __ ] coke bottle and you go
crack my name alex she was like let's do
this i'm not [ __ ]
[ __ ] wet no i got myself a baby boo
now we all gucci off the market baby
holler at me
don't holler at me but you know what i'm
saying that's [ __ ] ridiculous
so we're gonna go tyron woodley tyron
woodley sir
jake paul yep and i'm with you i don't
think i said 100
love nate diaz wish he didn't take this
fight yeah
if he wins thank god but i wish he
didn't take this fight
israel out of sonia marvin victory i'm
going izzy
is he all day bro ah you see how big his
dong is in that picture
he's like i wish he put those shorts on
backwards
a shout out to marvin victori for you
guys who don't watch fighting marvin
victoria is the number four number three
number three ranked middleweight in the
ufc he's been fighting for a very long
time for some [ __ ] reason he decided
on a very important fight the biggest
fight of his life he was going to wear
his shorts backwards
bro like he didn't feel that what about
the
[ __ ] photographer bro yeah how are
you not looking at me like
hey yo sir your your shorts are on
backwards but you know his short ass
temper he was scared of him dude
he's like shut up what you [ __ ] dick
he'll [ __ ] fight you is
literally the shortest fuse in the ufc
hands down bro like but he didn't feel
that
you know like right regular shorts you
put on backwards you feel that [ __ ] but
mma shorts
they're different it's
like you say like it's the back it's all
like pushing his pelvis yeah
you can't breathe if you look at the
photo
is it because the shorts are so tight
it's [ __ ] with his stance
so his pelvis is pushed back because the
shorts hey he has auntie poes
yo he does look like that bro he's all
auntied up
he's like [ __ ] you know what i saw i saw
the picture with his hand
i saw this [ __ ] like kevin holland's
thing right yeah and i was like yo kevin
hall in photoshop this [ __ ] yeah
that i looked like he just spotted his
shirt i just looked up the actual photo
bro it's real he wore his shorts
backwards
oh my god you are a professional [ __ ]
fighter you've done this multiple times
how do you put on
something i can't lose now bro because
if you lose all the [ __ ] you're talking
you put your shorts on backwards but i
and also someone else didn't put the
shorts on him he put them all back with
him
he was the one he's probably screaming
at the shorts like oh you [ __ ] you're
small
it's hard for me because i mean he like
he comes into the shop you know so like
we're like cool with
marvin that's my [ __ ] brother uh i'm
not saying he's not nice though he's
[ __ ] vicious he's got a good shot i
gotta get a shot against marvin i mean
uh
i'm gonna do heart and nah bro
[Music]
i think i think marvin king get it done
i don't think he finishes izzy in any
way
i honestly think it's gonna be like a
split decision win
i think it's gonna be something like
that where if he takes him down like i
feel like if he can get him to the floor
then marvin might be able to do some
work because marvin is big i've seen him
in person he's a big dude
and he is strong and he has good ground
game he showed that when he fought jack
her manson so
i think he i think marvin might be able
to take this away with a split decision
i low-key kind of think it's gonna be a
little bit of a boring fight i really do
you think it's gonna be similar to the
first fight
i do i think it's gonna be just like
that you know it's
i think their their styles uh
kind of even each other out even though
i feel like izzy is a way better striker
than him but
marvin just has that awkward style he's
a southpaw he's aggressive
um and i honestly he might be getting an
izzy's head this one and he got a chin
on him yeah he could take a shot and is
he is is he
getting like a little mad mad i feel
like this one i'll tell you this is
what's gonna happen
this is this is i believe brother
brother brother tori in the first two
rounds
is going to be very apprehensive he's
going to try to take him down a lot it's
going to fail a lot because of izzy's
takedown defense he's going to get
frustrated and he's going to try to
knock his block off and then izzy is
going to pick up
yeah i could definitely see that
happening too
this is actually like a it's weird
because i feel like it shouldn't be but
it's a really hard pick for me
this fight it's a really hard picture
for me every time every time i watch
the first fight again i think i'm like
dude marvin has a good shot
he does have a good shot but it's a
matter of
if he can't close the distance what do
you do that's it
and izzy was making good points he was
like look at ever since that fight
he said look at my resume and look at
marvin's resume
i mean he's kind of right marvin beat
[ __ ]
jacker mansion that's kind of like he
beat kevin holland too
yeah but kevin harlan hit the blueprint
was out there
on how to beat him and then kevin
holland just kept taking fights like a
week after
yeah cause everybody's gonna obviously
do the same [ __ ] to you right and the
marvin fight too with kevin holland like
it's not like it was a blowout buck no
it was still a very competitive fight in
favor of kevin holland
yeah so i mean it can definitely i i
just have
i have a weird feeling that marvin might
pull off like a split decision but let's
talk about this
what what did uh jan behovet say was the
most surprising thing about
his punching power his power isn't that
crazy john was like
john said they asked what was the most
surprising thing about asana he goes how
powerful he was
he was shocked at how strong his hits
were really which is nuts
could have fooled me huh the way he was
eating them yeah
yeah i'd be eating shots by anybody he
broke he's a blockhead for i'm so happy
i called that [ __ ]
[ __ ] i think jan if he moves up the
heavyweight he would give
a lot of people problems he hits huh
he's about to imagine right him not
cutting weight imagine him like
i don't know and ganu is so scary though
bro i don't mean like the top tier but
top ten he'll [ __ ] with a lot of them i
think top five bro yeah i think he'd be
up in
the top five i just don't see anybody
beating in ghani right now for a while
yeah i mean watching him have ground
game was scary dude yeah that was
probably the scariest thing i've ever
seen in my life
and even when he did the like all the
wrestling you could tell like it's still
something he's still like
learn and learn yeah like it's not as
like tight yet but
you watch him moving that athletic and
that big and that strong
you're like oh i don't know why stipe
was so light
why the [ __ ] was he yeah i don't that he
looks so depleted
yeah he came in a lot like that
supposedly i heard that he's trying to
gain back weight for
well he wants to fight him again yeah
because imagine if he had like i don't
know 10 or 15 pounds more or 20 pounds
more than he did before that step back
cross might have
actually hurt him would have rocked his
ass a little bit yeah and that's what he
thought he did he thought he rocked him
but he just slipped on the canvas
bro and then also too like in ganu like
he's 260
lean yeah yep like that's hard to
replace in shape now too he's not that
260 like when he first watched deep
where he was kind of just like you know
head like heavy
yeah like not cut now he's 260 cut yeah
so it's like
it looks like he has more muscle on him
too yeah and then gonna too you know
matter what because he's so big
he he was still breathing out of his
mouth pretty heavy yeah even when he was
in it with stipe if that went further i
think stippy would have had it yeah
that's because that's gonna be the true
test right is how long francis
can do that that output that's why
watching him if i
uh quote unquote john africa that's why
john africa maybe not my boy john africa
down africa
uh jon jones that it'd still be an
interesting fight to me
i would like to see that because i'd
like to see if he's ever going to fight
yeah bro that [ __ ] that'll be [ __ ] i
shouldn't low key i'm a big jon jones
fan but this [ __ ]
like gets annoying every once in a while
i'm like on twitter now bro
[ __ ] fight bro god damn you heard it
here first dude
alice is gonna beat the [ __ ] out of jon
jones john africa
john africa i'll be john africa
i don't know well guys that wraps up
this episode of the genius brain podcast
we had a little fight talk we had a
little alex acosta action here
hey try this which one is this raspberry
that's the raspberry delicious
i have blueberry blueberries and these
new shaker cups too right there
everybody
damn hi where can they find you alex uh
lift god on everything l-i-f-f-g-o-d-d
and
uh we out here mma let's go yeah and
then
nick the ear and we out here the most
unenthusiastic plug i've ever heard of
my phone i don't i don't like plugging
myself no
do it like you're [ __ ] colby
covington right now uh but
put your hat straight though just like
there you go
um you can find me at nicktheare.com and
nick you're on instagram
and we out here mma on youtube and
spotify it's like listening
to [ __ ] spotify spotify oh nick
started making music bro even though he
wouldn't send me a [ __ ] clip
of him saying one word nah we were me
and tiff were in the fight that day i
didn't want it
all right guys thank you for tuning in
to geniusbrain see you guys next week
the worst promo ever we'll see y'all
next time peace